so in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones Westeros is divided by a big icy
wall - it's south of the Seven Kingdoms
with all that cities and castles and
ladies and Lords and almost all the main
characters in the series north of the
wall is a vast frozen wilderness
populated by people known as the
wildlings the wildlings are in trouble
because recently they've been under
attack from the mysterious others or
White Walkers Mance Rayder the
king-beyond-the-wall who unites and
leads the wildlings tries to fight the
White Walkers at first but he can't
stand against them so instead he decides
to lead his people to safety south of
the wall but the Nights Watch who manned
the wall see the wildlings as enemies as
dangerous savages and they don't want to
let them through so mance determined to
get his people south prepares to do
something drastic
he searches for an ancient artifact said
to have the power to break the wall
something called Jorah means horn or the
Horn of winter man searches for the horn
in the Frostfangs and all over the
valley of the milk water digging up half
a hundred graves of ancient kings and
heroes Ygritte tells John that for all
their searching the wildlings never find
the horn but later in storm matt says
the eager lied and that he did find it
he shows John a great war horn eight
feet long banded in gold and graved with
runes matt says that unless the watch
lets the wildlings through the wall
he'll blow the horn and destroy the wall
even though he knows that if the wall
Falls there'll be nothing to stop the
others in the end Stannis captures mance
and Melisandre burns the horn and Jon
Matt's many of the wildlings through the
wall anyway so it looks like the story
of the horn is cut short but later
tormund tells John that manses horn
wasn't actually the real horn that it
was an empty threat
so Jon asks if mansis horn was just a
feint where is the true horn we might
also ask what the horn actually does
exactly and who made it and why whenever
directly given answers to these
questions in the text but we can make
some pretty good guesses let's start at
the beginning with German according to
legend German was the first
king-beyond-the-wall the first person to
unite and lead the wildlings
he lived thousands of years ago so we
don't really know anything about him for
certain but we hear a few different
stories Jill Marmont implies that German
tried to invade the south but was
defeated either by the wall or by the
Starks of Winterfell in another story
German apparently fought alongside the
Starks in the overthrow of the night's
king a Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch who seemed to be involved with the
others but the main thing we're told
about German is that he blew the Horn of
winter and woke chants from the earth
which apparently means the Horn has the
power to bring down the wall so these
legends raised a lot of questions like
if blowing the Horn of winter brings
down the wall and joram and blew the
Horn of winter why is the wall still
standing was the horn not used to its
full power or maybe not directed at the
wall or something and a German tried to
invade the south or did he fight with
the Starks against the night's king or
both was the horn used in these
conflicts and most of all what does it
mean to wake Giants from the earth fans
have lots of different ideas about what
this phrase means like maybe it's
literal maybe there are giants in some
kind of hibernation under the ground and
the sound of the horn will wake them and
make them tear down the wall some
suggest that there are ice dragons
frozen within the wall or huge weirwood
trees that could be described as Giants
because evidence for a different
explanation in the world of Ice and Fire
and the bit about the breaking of the
arm of dawn basically thousands of years
ago the first humans came to Westeros
across a land bridge called the arm of
dawn
they started warring with the children
of the forest so to try to stop more
humans coming the children used the
magic of the old gods to break the arm
the old gods stirred and Giants awoke in
the earth and all of Westeros shook and
trembled
great cracks appeared in the earth and
hills and mountains collapsed and was
swallowed up but then the Seas came
rushing in and the arm of dawn was
broken leaving only a few bare rocky
islands that we see today
so George our Martin uses waking Giants
from the earth as a metaphor for a huge
earth-shaking Cataclysm presumably
that's where the Horn of winter does and
that's how it could destroy the wall
this may also hint at the horns origins
it sounds like the horn uses the magic
of the children of the forest but the
physical form of the horn itself seems
like something humans would make
especially if it's banded in metal which
we know the children didn't use so maybe
the horn was made by the children of the
four
and the first men working together which
makes sense because the horn dates back
to a time of friendship and peace
between the children and the men in fact
it was not long before German that the
children and the men apparently worked
together to defeat the others and build
the wall which raises another question
why would the children and the men make
a horn that can destroy the wall just
after they built the wall maybe this
supports the theory that the wall was
actually built by the others but if the
children and the men actually wanted to
destroy the wall why put that power into
a horn instead of just using that power
on destroying the wall right away maybe
the horn was designed not to destroy the
wall but as a power play to show that
you could bring down the wall kind of
like nukes in the Cold War
being able to threaten someone with
complete destruction can be more
powerful than actually destroying them
this is what Mance Rayder does in storm
right he doesn't want to use the horn to
bring down the wall because he knows
that that would make everyone vulnerable
to the others but he threatens to do it
anyway to force the watch to do what he
wants maybe that's why the horn was made
in the first place not to destroy the
wall but as a way to project power by
showing you could destroy the wall it
might have been first used against the
night's king the night's king apparently
took over the Nights Watch on the wall
with strange sorceries and made
sacrifices to the others maybe the way
the wildlings and stalks defeated him
was by threatening to use the horn
maybe German sounded it at less than its
full power enough to show that he could
destroy the wall without actually doing
it in doing so forcing the night's king
to stand down that's just a guess
there's no solid evidence to support
this but it does make sense for the horn
to be designed more as a threat than to
be actually used to speculate a little
more we can also guess at where the horn
was kept after the business with German
or the night's king maybe the Horn of
winter was held by the stock kings of
winter at Winterfell maybe that's why it
said that there must always be a stark
in Winterfell
the Starks historically guarded the Horn
maybe the horn was kept in the
Winterfell crypts there are lots of
hints that there's something important
down there both Brian and John have many
dreams about the crypts also Mance
Rayder has shown a suspicious interest
in the crypts he actually infiltrates
Winterfell twice in the first book and
in dance
mance is still alive in the books in
downs mance gets into window fell and
tries to find out from Thea
on where the crypts are is it possible
that mance believes that the Horn of
winter is in the crypts is that why he
keeps on sneaking into Winterfell
maybe we'll find out in the next book
but it's also possible that the horns
are not in Winterfell anymore if it ever
was because it seems likely that the
Horn of winter is now in the possession
of Samwell Tarly in Clash John finds a
cache of dragonglass weapons wrapped in
a Night's Watch cloak and buried on the
fist of the first men
possibly by benjin or cold hands for
Bloodraven along with the dragonglass
daggers and arrowheads is an old war
horn made from an ore ox horn and banded
in bronze it's cracked and chipped and
John can get any sound from it so he
gives it to Sam who likes old things
even worthless old things basically this
one doesn't seem to be important but Sam
hangs on to it and the books keep subtly
reminding us that he still has it four
times in two books the horn is
offhandedly mentioned often right after
John chapters where he mentions the Horn
of winter why would this horn keep
coming up unless it was important it
looks like George Martin is setting us
up to reveal that Sam's worthless old
horn is actually the legendary horn of
winter which could lead to some pretty
crazy [ __ ] happening like what would
happen if Sam repairs and blows the horn
while he's in Old Town with the wall
suddenly fall hundreds of miles away or
if the horn is like directional wood old
town collapse around Sam it's also worth
considering that magic in this story
especially the magic of the old gods
often has a cost of blood or human life
when someone uses another magic horn in
the story Dragan binder his lips blister
and his chest bleeds and he ends up dead
whoever uses Germans horn might suffer
something similar there is an
interesting symmetry between the fiery
dragon binder and the icy horn of winter
also there's apparently a magic horn
that summons Krakens from the deep which
sounds pretty sick but anyway we could
speculate all day about Germans horn but
here's our best guesses based on what we
know now
according to legend it's an ancient horn
with the power to bring down the wall it
was probably originally made by the
children of the forest on the first man
maybe not because they wanted to destroy
the wall but because they wanted to be
able to threaten to destroy it like a
mutually assured destruction type deal
after German and the night's king the
horn may have been kept by the Starks in
the Winterfell
trips though now it seems likely the
horn is held by samwell tarly in the
citadel which could have hilarious
and/or disastrous consequences we'll
hopefully learn more about the horn in
the next book it's apparently on the
cover after all
until then we'll keep on guessing thanks
for watching for more Game of Thrones
discussion and analysis you might like
to check out the Song of Ice and Fire
subreddit and Westeros dog many thanks
to all the patrons including xandria
leonard mr. Fifer si Cameron Weiss Vanya
dog Michael lapels yet Alec we Matthew
Elijah Williams Fred petty Andrew Noonan
david McNamee jon dykes ruby good night
Jenny Alvarado and Nikole Killion feel
free to like and subscribe and comment
below what you'd like to see next
Cheers